il était très sociable
il opéra toujours de la même façon il se
liait avec une femme il tombait à ses
pieds il lui offrait une bague ça
c'était obligatoire ensuite il lui
faisait croire qu'il parlait d'elle à
ses parents et lui promettait moins et
merveilles
alors dès que ce bel avenir semblait
menacé les femmes étaient prêtes à
donner leur dernier sous
gâteau
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec Olga en
moins de 8 mois elle va lui prêter 40
000 euros
tribunal de villechinovegora dans Russie
cet homme derrière les barreaux comparé
aujourd'hui devant le juge il est
français
dans sa cage il attend d'être fixé sur
son sort
déclinez votre identité
pitchelli Franck
vous pouvez répéter polyvitch
polyvitch ce n'est pas votre vrai nom
non
polyvitch est un patronyme inventé
l'accusé s'appelle en fait Franck
picholi il est accusé d'escroquerie et
d'abus de confiance il aurait séduit et
volé des dizaines de femmes toutes
russes
pour ces faits il risque jusqu'à 10 ans
de prison
acceptez-vous les charges retenues
contre vous oui
cette affaire fait la une des médias en
Russie
bio par veille mais la romance se
terminait une fois qu'il obtenait ce
qu'il voulait une nouvelle voiture et un
crédit pour ses projets
n'a pas le physique que l'on prête
habituellement au séducteurs et pourtant
en 12 ans il a collectionné les
conquêtes en Russie et aurait multiplié
les arnaques
il me demandait d'aller à la banque il
me surveillait quand je retirais
l'argent au guichet et à la fin je lui
remettais la Somme
c'était un escroc mais c'était un
charmeur à la française
[Musique]
qui est vraiment Frank pitchelli se
séducteur comment s'y prenait-il pour
séduire ses femmes et s'en prendre à
leur compte en banque
tout commence en France à la fin des
années 90 dans la région lyonnaise où
Franck Piccioli a longtemps habité
[Musique]
marié père d'un enfant il est batteur
dans une école de musique qui la fondée
avec Anne et Pascal rapidement ces
associés vont découvrir que l'homme
n'est pas celui qu'il croit mais je me
souvenais plus des montants des factures
tu te rends compte
au bout de quelques temps années parce
qu'elle réalise qu'il détourne
d'importantes sommes d'argent de l'école
lorsqu'il porte plainte il découvre
qu'il en fait un lourd passif Franck
picholi a déjà été condamné pour de
multiples escroqueries
que tout simplement porter plainte
auprès de la police
fonction des du vol de la batterie de
plus de 20000 francs à l'époque et c'est
là où on a découvert auprès de la police
que Monsieur ternescroc connu reconnu
voilà
et que elle était fichée depuis une
bonne dizaine d'années et qui était sous
le coup de 17 condamnations
17 condamnations la plainte de l'école
et la plainte de trop Franck Piccioli
prend la fuite c'est la première de ses
nombreuses cavales
[Musique]
il quitte la France et s'installe dans
une toute petite ville au cœur de la
Russie
[Musique]
Anna et sa première conquête elle lui
apprend à parler le russe Franck lui n'a
pas de travail c'est sa femme qui le
fait vivre
deux ans
il faisait des petits travaux dans mon
atelier de couture et il réparait des
machines à coudre
anna était très amoureuse de pitchouli
ils ont eu deux enfants
ça c'est dans un parc aquatique
c'est vrai qu'il a beaucoup de charme je
ne peux pas dire qu'il soit bel homme
mais il a un je ne sais quoi qui vous
séduit il savait se rendre séduisant
mais très vite il commence à avoir des
comportements étranges il disparaît
pendant de longs mois
où était-il mystère il finissait
toujours par revenir il pouvait rester
six mois et puis il disparaissait de
nouveau de la circulation pendant deux
ans il me menait en bateau je sentais
bien qu'il me faisait des cachotteries
mais à chaque fois qu'il refait surface
il couvrait les enfants de cadeaux
je fermais les yeux et gober toutes ces
histoires
[Musique]
mais ce mode de vie modeste au milieu de
nulle part ne semble plus convenir à
Frank picholi il part pour une plus
grande ville cazant à 100 km de là ici
pitchiolis invente un nouveau métier
prof de kendji do un art martial surgit
de nulle part dont il a créé le nom et
les règles
dans ce centre sportif il gagne vite la
confiance de Timour le directeur
il savait fédérer les gens il avait un
vrai talent pour ça
il y avait beaucoup de gens ici et leur
promettait à tous des tournois en France
et ils s'entraînait pour ça il avait le
don pour vendre un vrai talent
dans la région il devient vite une
attraction
la télé locale lui consacre même un
reportage
devant la caméra il s'invente un passé
glorieux
j'étais entraîneur de judo avant en
charge de l'équipe olympique réserve de
la Fédération française de judo
ensuite j'ai dirigé la fédération de
kenjido
[Musique]
ïse se présente comme une légende du
sport français et du coup gagne la
confiance des gens il se fait prêter de
l'argent facilement il emprunte à
l'équipe du Centre des sommes de plus en
plus importantes
mais c'était des toutes petites sommes
pour les plus grosses sommes il disait
toujours demain demain
il devient de plus en plus gourmand du
coup Timour commence à avoir des doutes
sur l'homme et ses qualités de judoka
un jour j'ai fini par lui demander
qu'est-ce qui prouve que tu es prof de
judo et il m'a dit demain je t'apporte
la preuve et voilà la photo qui m'a
rapporté vous voyez sa tête est beaucoup
plus grosse que l'autre c'est simplement
un photomontage
Timour n’entendra plus jamais parler de
pitchelli il disparaît sans rembourser
les milliers d'euros qu'il doit
fini la carrière de grands sportif le
français semble alors changer de
stratégie il va désormais viser les
femmes et leur compte en banque
une technique qu'il mette en place dans
ce cabaret où il s'invente un nouveau
personnage chanteur de charme
j'ai écrit cette chanson quand j'avais
20 ans
c'était il y a 23 ans
[Musique]
allez chantons tous ensemble
encore un mensonge cette chanson est un
tube des années 80
[Musique]
désormais le chanteur dit s'appelait
Andrea Cutugno il se dit italien
et sa technique marche
[Musique]
parmi ces admiratrices Olga elle a été
séduite par le chanteur
elle nous reçoit dans sa datcha à 100 km
de Moscou
[Musique]
je chantais très bien surtout les
chansons françaises mais aussi des
chansons italiennes il y avait beaucoup
de charme il était très sociable
il opérit toujours de la même façon il
se lie avec une femme il tombait à ses
pieds il lui offrait une bague ça
c'était obligatoire ensuite il lui
faisait croire qu'il parlait d'elle à
ses parents et lui promettait monts et
merveilles
menacé les femmes étaient prêtes à
donner leur dernier sous
[Musique]
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec Olga en
moins de 8 mois elle va lui prêter 40
000 euros
car Piccioli lui fait croire qu'il n'est
pas qu'un chanteur de cabaret c'est un
entrepreneur qui a de l'ambition
et des projets de
business il m'emmenait à la banque et il
m'attendait à la sortir à chaque fois je
lui donnais l'argent et il partait faire
une affaire
le dernier souvenir Colga conserve du
crooner c'est une vidéo qui dit avoir
enregistré rien que pour elle
[Musique]
mais ni les textes ni la musique ne sont
de lui
et encore moins la voix
[Musique]
j'espère qu'il pleure pour toutes les
femmes qu'il a arnaqué je l'espère
vraiment
Carole garnit pas la seule femme à être
victime de pitchioli elles sont en fait
plusieurs dizaines en Russie
yeva mercatcheva et journaliste dans un
quotidien russe elle a été l'une des
premières à s'intéresser à la faire elle
a dénombré 40 victimes au total
des femmes sincèrement amoureuses
[Musique]
disaient qu'il possédait toutes les
qualités qui font défaut aux hommes
russes et dont rêvent leurs femmes pitch
il leur disait souvent vos mecs ne sont
bons qu'à boire et à faire la fête il ne
respectent rien nous les Italiens
allaient savoir pourquoi il se
présentait comme italien nous adulons la
beauté des femmes leur âme
une grande chaîne de télé lui consacre
même un long reportage de nouveaux
témoignages apparaissent comme celui de
Nadia enceinte de pitchioli
il est parti avec ma tablette mon
ordinateur une caméra tout mon matériel
hi-fi
il a même pris la télévision qui était
celle du propriétaire
il a aussi volé l'argent qu'on avait mis
de côté pour acheter la voiture
l'émission est vue par des millions de
personnes la pression est trop forte
pitchouli sait qu'il va être reconnu
dans tout le pays il décide de se rendre
à la police
mais avant cela il appelle Nadia sa
dernière victime elle enregistre leur
conversation nous nous sommes procurés
cette enregistrement
je voulais te dire que mon vrai nom
c'est Franck pitchelli c'est maintenant
que tu penses à moi tu sais que tu vas
avoir un enfant je n'ai pas la tête à ça
tu sais je vais prendre 50 goulags là
j'aimerais vivre tranquillement au moins
une journée dans ma vie deux heures
après ce coup de téléphone il se rend
dans ce poste de police c'est la fin
d'une course folle qui aura duré 15 ans
[Musique]
lors de sa comparution devant le juge
son avocat de commise d'office a refusé
de nous parler
Franck pitchelli attend désormais son
procès dans la prison de velikinovegorod
il aura lieu dans un an